behind me is like Constance it is a big
lake near the Alps in the middle of
Europe this bit of me is in Germany and
this bit of me on the other side of that
sculpture is in Switzerland they took
down the border fence and they replaced
it with sculptures a few miles away
behind me over that horizon is Austria
and all three countries have a shoreline
on Lake Constance but if you look at a
map you will notice that something is
missing the lines that denote where the
international borders are the lines that
I'm standing on right now stop at the
lakeshore Lake Constance is a
condominium which is a fancy way of
saying that it belongs to more than one
country but no one's entirely sure who
we are used to the idea that the earth
is divided up and different countries
own different bits of it which is kind
of a strange idea when it's put like
that but since most of the world agrees
on it we stick with it laws taxes rights
and responsibilities change at formal
defined lines okay there are
international waters and Antarctica is a
special case and okay there is that one
bit of Africa what two countries both
don't want to claim it but generally
each bit of the world is owned by one
particular nation and sure sometimes
borders get complicated because of
treaty glitches or land disputes but
this isn't one of those it's just that
no one ever bothered to actually put
down in an international treaty where
the borders are according to Austria
over there Lake Constance is a true
condominium shared equally by all three
countries all the way across if you are
on the lake then you are simultaneously
in Germany and Austria and Switzerland
Switzerland is not happy with that
according to them the border runs
straight down the middle of a lake and
Germany is basically like yeah no one
really has a problem with this if there
are any legal issues then settled on a
case-by-case basis so if you're
wondering what happens if someone gives
birth in the middle of the lake and what
citizenship their kid would have or what
would happen under Salvage laws if
someone pulled up sunken treasure from
the moment the the answer is yeah we'll
sort it out when we have to and in the
meantime no one's really going to mind
the only people that this lack of
defying border effects are cartographers
map makers there is no option on
digital maps for their computers and
people don't know where to draw the line
you